as promised to continue to hype
ourselves up for dc fandom
we covered everything great about man of
steel last week and now today
we are covering from cinema wins
everything great
about batman v superman ultimate edition
but before we look back on the better
aspects
of one of the most hotly debated films
in recent memory i want to say a quick
thank you to today's video sponsor
giant panda king you know i'm a master
debater
really john that's what you're going
with well yeah i mean i i was trying to
write this shout out in your voice wow
john that
is completely inappropriate i would
never joke like that especially when i'm
about to let people know
that gpk is probably best known for
their touring bird last show
the empire strips back set in the star
wars universe
and there's really no debating the
immersive quality of their
wook erotica series which takes a 1970s
pinup magazine and
reimagines it through the star wars lens
they're going to love this gpk
but if i'm being serious my favorite
thing has got to be
their gotham 1919-1939 book ate this bad
boy up in a couple of days
it takes the characters and laura batman
and reimagines them as part of
depression era american history
love it so much bbk is really taking fan
made content to a whole other level the
production values the character designs
takes on the world the attention to
detail is so unique i masterfully
debated this book
if you know what i mean you have a
batman-oriented role-play fetish so hit
up that link in the description box and
pin comment to check out everything
giant panda king has to offer
masterful
[Music]
the comedian never knows when to quit
but at least negan isn't killing maggie
in this scene
yeah fair one thing zack snyder's proven
he's good at it's slow motion pistol
firing that's right ups the ante this
time with a hammer and slide scattering
the iconic pearls
so you have to like hook it the zimmer
score is ridiculously fantastic
not even talking about each main
character's theme yet the in-between
moments are beautiful
the music is something that sets the dc
eu apart and elevates it above the rest
we've seen it countless times by now but
snyder still injects some new poetic
life into the death of the wanes you may
think that's
yeah i didn't hate that scene everyone
seemed to bag on it
man of steel was told through the
perspective of kal-el a lot of this
story and definitely this opening
sequence is seen through our eyes
this ah everyone running away while
bruce wayne runs into the unknown
towards the battle that's some cinematic
goals amen to that brother
this opening sequence is one of the best
story setups ever in just plain grey
we saw this battle on the other side
giving us that insider feeling but it's
still portrayed as chaotic and confusing
how many aliens are there who's fighting
whom it's exactly how terrifying this
would be for us tiny little humans
and there could be no better reason for
bruce to start hating superman than this
pan out from a young girl losing her
parents paralleling bruce's own past
yes yes dude that's fair i mean there's
some silly things that happened in that
scene but there's a lot of greatness
hence the point of this video tying the
two films together with more ethereal
underwater weightlessness
they did not tell me the interview was
with the lady i'm not a lady i'm a
journalist
i'm never a huge fan of straight up evil
henchmen but kg beast is a pretty
intimidating dude
it's the one role that gets placed in
every time i see
superman edition super bad murderers
batman begins was great but jumping
right into the third act of batman's
journey is really refreshing we're
introduced to batfleck with his new
brand and almost horror movie style
stalking in the corner and then his
wicked creepy scurry across the ceiling
exactly how you should feel about the
dark knight water conservation through
bath sharing
[Laughter]
[Music]
justification but that's set up enough
for me to forgive all the killing
even alfred says that bruce is changing
slash has changed turns good man
yeah fairly large point of contention
kill mark zuckerberg himself
i think his over-the-top slightly
mentally unglued personality is a breath
of fresh air compared to what everyone
would expect
from lex and rocky i agree i know you do
stopping around like he owns the place
since he pretty much does considering
the vast number of things he
orchestrates to get a god and the
world's best detective to battle it out
and lexus theme is another perfect fit
for the power hungry fearless cherry
jolly randy
loving psychopath he is watch yourself
over there and got them i want them to
take too much money
apparently perry hasn't seen this i'm
not a cop
i'm a reporter amazing great scene
people wouldn't care but spending some
time with clark kent journalisting it up
gives us some clients it helped this
cut so much having that scene but i love
this little glimpse into the strategist
that batman is
just by observing he notices a weakness
in an opponent that completely turns the
tide of the fight
magical thinking of orphan boys blocking
the import license for your mineral
credit where credit is due luther's
quirky upbeat facade cracks and twitches
to that news and eisenberg plays it
exceptionally well
few things here how fitting is it that
the world engine is the sound that
haunts bruce wayne's dreams
next my interpretation of what emerges
from martha's crypt is the manifestation
of alfred's warnings
and bruce's subconscious fear of the bat
taking over control yeah
just amanda no
and i personally wholeheartedly believe
this to be pretense he has clear social
anxiety and he uses the semblance of
extroversion as a cover for how sinister
he actually is
also for those confused by his
motivations he spells them out right
here the bittersweet pain among men
is having knowledge with no power
because that is paradoxical
and superman superman
and another beautiful scene scored so
subtly and elegantly
a superman saving people montage is the
fastest way to fail to make up for his
supposed negligence and man of steel
wait let me try again a superman saving
people montage is the fastest way to
somehow still piss off the fanbook
jim who wrote this
[Music]
who watches the watchmen i never noticed
that damn
are filmmakers starting to listen to
jeremy and chris because i have some
great videos for you that all start with
dear hollywood if you're interested
i just have to point out how much of
what is going on right now is being
orchestrated by luther to pit our heroes
against each other
passing off one inmate about to be
murdered as directed by luther pissing
soups off
to another inmate wally who becomes the
unwilling suicide bomber pissing batman
off
i can't even piss standing up now
well this is important i need you to say
this exactly like it says in the script
i wrote for you but
i'm really not so sure i can say piss to
a senator trust me it's an inside joke
she'll get it
bruce the creeper
i like that it's actually a fair
assumption given selena kyle pamela
eisley miranda tate harley quinn
[Music]
oh i don't think you've ever known a
woman like me
another premonition vision dream
nightmare
signal by the way yo this sequence is
pretty dope does batman get any cooler
than in this trench coat
another amazing long take single cup
schneider cut just
solid and nearly unbreakable as batman
is bad fleck and possibly a stunt double
earned his spot in this universe with
this one set piece
the nightmare sequence works on multiple
levels for the casual moviegoer it's
bruce's worst fears realized than a
manifestation of what he believes about
superman
scary stuff for the comic fan or the
casual movie gore willing to do a little
research
it's the flash warning batman about the
potential slash alternate injustice
feature where superman becomes a tyrant
ruler whether it's just a nod to
hardcore fans with dark sides omega
symbol and pair of demons or a set up
for the justice league villain
and a little bit of evidence that it
wasn't just a bad dream or the paper
still floating through the air
to destroy good call
i've always been debated then
again i'm not trying to be crass but
since this film has been called
confusing i feel the need to point out
these spoon-fed thematic lines
these are the questions this film asks
and while it's the main thing driving
batman to confrontation with superman
bruce is going to answer it about
himself very soon ew batmobile is dope
and this chase scene is one of the best
involving batman with car crushing some
man
whatever you want to call this awesome
just aside and then this happens
you asked for do you plead
what a punch to the gut holly hunter
really killed it in this scene
or got killed by it no matter what clark
does he feels lost
alone and like no decision he makes is
ever without casualty and the look on
his
face while surrounded by what we can
only assume is pure horror says it all
jeremy irons is just the man he doesn't
replace past alfreds but he's able to
carry a scene all by himself exquisitely
right out of arkham city
fat flex workout routine and of course a
batfleck training battle prep montage is
the fastest way to kill superman
i've already raved about the score but
for me wonder woman's takes the freaking
cake
that's that is still a very silly scene
some defensive movies
remember this hundred thousand different
worlds
teach me that's good enough for me with
carla cugino as a teacher how could he
go wrong
how's carla gogino huh not lana
another scene we were a bit confused by
but it's just a visual representation of
clark's struggle
should he even bother superman knowing
there will always be consequences in
collateral damage
yes that's some classic superman for you
right there
always there to comfort lois lane even
when he's saving your life god is all
all-powerful
he cannot be all good lex lays it out
for us again and this wasn't a secret
kept for the ultimate edition
lex hates god for myriad reasons most of
which seems to come from the abuse he
endured at his father's hands that he
feels god did not protect him from now
that he has a physical embodiment of
superman he can finally have his revenge
all these justice league cameos are
great but miles dyson messing with
cyborg
did you learn nothing from t2 well
here i am when the first trailer dropped
i actually shared it on facebook with
the one complaint that they hadn't
seemed to have learned their lesson
after the backlash from bale's bat voice
i stand so corrected the voice modulator
is awesome the bat mech suit is
lego batman
that first little touch like flicking a
fly love it
people complain that soup should have
tried harder to explain really
you wouldn't be a little annoyed and his
plan even after all this was still to
subdue bruce into listening
as much as i can't wait for them to be
buddies it's fun to see bats kick a
little butt
no i i think i i think soups could have
talked
all right let's see your reasoning here
we go again from what i can gather this
is the moment lots of people
especially the critics turned off their
brains this is not my usual defense of
the indefensible this is plain as day
fact
if you didn't get it please pay
attention let's see batman does not
spare superman because their mothers
share the same name
batman has spent 18 months obsessing
over killing this alien who can destroy
the earth
it isn't until superman uses the name
that the alien becomes humanized
at first batman becomes even more
enraged because he thinks it's another
trick
once he realizes it's clark's mom's name
he starts to understand that maybe
they're not so different
he never considered the evil alien had a
human mother or let alone would be
willing to die for her
bruce couldn't save his mother no matter
how many goons batman brands he was a
helpless kid when she was killed just
like clark is now
he'll never bring his marker back now he
has an opportunity for redemption
it literally has nothing to do with
their mothers having the same name
that was just a spark that you can see
snapping bruce out of his kill rage that
showed him superman wasn't pure evil
with potentially his last breath he
asked his killer to save someone else i
mean i wouldn't
say it's not confusing it's not grasping
at straws it's in the narrative
it's the entire reason we were shown the
murder of the waynes one more time this
moment goes down as one of the biggest
problems amongst the center
when it's actually one of the most
emotionally stirring and theme
appropriate scenes if you're paying
attention
and the reason he decided to team up
with supes is because he's finally able
to listen to logic now that the kill
rage is gone
new batwing is amazing well things they
got so right
the new suits we'll talk about
the way the suit looks battle worn and
how it's the most comic accurate ever
and now we come to possibly the best
pieces of this fight back gadgets
attacks from above like
i never liked this fight
[Music]
i figured the gate saving your new
friend's mom
fears fine whatever i don't really care
at this point i look at it as an excuse
to unite all of our heroes and give
superman a way to prove how far he's
willing to go
exactly totally fine and he's
sufficiently scary and powerful
saving your enemy superman's alive
[Music]
and my brain exploded from far far far
too much awesome
wonder woman literally doesn't not steal
any scene she's in double negative for
effect
and her theme kills i don't care that i
already gave it a win it kills
whatever it could have been a big old
bag of marshmallows angry marshmallows
obviously
but seeing these three work together
especially with wonder woman now is
so winning oh yeah it should go without
saying that this final fight is epic
everything about it is epictastic and
the epicity of wonder woman is
epitacular and not a single second of
epicness let us down
i mean i'm saying it anyway so epic
a little smirk like she's having a grand
old time
[Music]
now that's some teamwork self-sacrifice
some of the most meaningful
self-sacrifice ever even after this
world rejects him he still is willing to
die for it because he believes
this is my world and whether he's dead
for five years or five minutes he still
gave up his life to save humanity
one more score went for the beautiful
coral voices yeah
perfect stage setter yeah don't seem to
get too upset when they showed thanos at
the end of avengers but this this upsets
everyone
well you don't know what we can find
just remember the fantasy will set you
free
also gross the juxtaposition of the
simple farm boy funeral the military
funeral is a great final illustration of
clark's duality
got my checkbook to pay the funeral
director oh how interesting
my home anonymous donor must have been
ihop
dude's creeping again help me find the
others like you perhaps they don't want
to be found
they will and they'll fight yeah justice
league
call it a primo nightshin
right in the dark among the stars
if you really want to hate eisenberg
just write it off like he's being
controlled by darkseid
easy enough
as you've realized by now i chose the
ultimate edition because number one
i wanted to and number two this channel
has always been about the great
things that actors directors composers
cinematographers and even the occasional
producers do
not the studios the studio cut this film
down from snyder's vision and left it
the theatrical mess it was
this version was the film we were meant
to see at the end of the day i feel some
real deep sadness for a lot of the fans
who didn't like this movie
especially dc comic fans okay because
the rest of us got a sensational batman
superman movie
oh and just for fun the best wonder
woman representation moreover call this
a cop
out but had this movie come out 10 years
ago everyone would have lost their minds
but we're so spoiled we'd be
hard-pressed to enjoy a simple
beat-em-up batman v superman movie
not even mentioning the story-driven one
we were given i'm not saying it doesn't
have flaws and reusing characters that
have been portrayed in the past is
always a risk and always upset some
people
true but the characterizations were
unique and apropos of this universe
it came up the major deal but superman
is alone in this planet lois does the
best she can but ultimately this movie
shows us how solitary he feels yeah
this film was a perfect continuation for
man of steel and how he dealt with the
aftermath of those events leading to his
ultimate sacrifice for his foreign world
he calls home
no one will ever forgive my joke about
bat flak at the end of my man of steel
video
but none among you saw his performance
coming that's obviously true i'm
defending at this point
was great this cake crusader on the
other hand gets some hate for a couple
reasons
killing and killing with guns are the
biggest issues and while batman does
occasionally kill in the comics anyway i
think the bigger puzzle piece here is
the type of batman we're actually
getting and where he is in his journey
this is a war-hardened jaded grizzled
robin-less joke
that's his arc it's the whole point he
spends the first half of the movie
hunting superman and planning his
murder not to beat the dead martha horse
but that was his turning point
he looked into the mirror and saw joe
chill or whoever killed his parents in
this continuity
at that moment he returns to the batman
we know and love evidence by sparing lex
and not even branding him
lex was quirky and goofy and not the
luxury right oh dude
do you pick up on such little things i
don't pick up on
they just couldn't have spelled it out
more he hated his father he hates god he
believes the oldest lion america to be
that power can be innocent and most
importantly he wants that power for
himself i'm sorry that his ultimate plan
wasn't about real estate this time
fingers crossed for next time i'm not
going to go too much deeper into the
story other than to say if you went into
this expecting a relatively
straightforward marvel type plot
just stop doing that the dceu is not the
mcu
the dceu is somber i agree but it's not
without humor did you find the sphere
most of which comes from batman and
alfred but superman had a few minors too
i don't know how to lose you'll learn
there weren't multiple stories in this
movie
unless you want to call setting up the
justice league a separate story but even
that bruce is setting it up because he
just witnessed doomsday
so the superman sequel discussion of
should there be a superman and who
watches the watchmen was a direct setup
for the batman story
how far is bruce willing to go until he
realizes he's becoming the very thing he
set out to stop
it's a line right out of aaron eckhart's
version of harvey dense mouth in the
dark knight
yeah you either die a hero or you live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain
could this have been two movies sure
doesn't mean the story was difficult to
follow
if nothing else i hope this encourages
you to go watch the ultimate edition if
you haven't already
it is worth your time in the end we got
a lot more of lex's plan and how
intricate it was with everything he's
set up and how he attempts to frame
superman very true against him
i also appreciate the extra motivation
for clark throughout his investigation
of the bat
while i stand by the theatrical is still
a pretty decent movie the studio removed
some of the heart
and really butchered a lot of the flow
by just randomly moving scenes around
like this one
since they cut genome alone scenes they
interspersed this bathroom scene in the
middle of batman's getting ready for the
party scene
just so bizarre they just reordered
random cuts
i really hope the studio learns from
this next time and just releases the
original cut
take the loss of an extra showing and
realize that the millions of dollars you
forfeited from those immediate negative
reviews would have been far made up by
the tens of thousands of people who
decided not to go to this movie based on
a 27
rotten tomato score or ignore us and
keep doing what you're doing obviously
zack snyder is just a hack
it's not like this is the third time his
vision for the movie has been the better
version
everyone totally loved watchmen and
sucker punchers theatrical versions
totally and i totally take back
everything i said about my faith in
snyder and goyer
totally but best luck man have you seen
reindeer games
you will that you will
you're a thought-provoking mother effort
cinema wins
gotta be vibranium stop provoking
you know how to make a good argument oh
really for sure
really too yeah when movie fights comes
back on screen junkies you should go
there oh
heck yeah i mean i gotta give it to him
like for cinema wins hey let me just say
that i do prefer the ultimate edition
cut
way over the theatrical cut and it's
weird how extra 15 to 20 minutes can
make
the world of difference like i agree
with his closing statements about that
he hopes people check out the ultimate
edition instead
especially for like the clark
investigating batman elements adding
more weight and credence to
why he doesn't trust batman actually
from watching his man of
steel video talking about the lesson
that he probably learned from killing
zod
of why he even hates batman that much
more and also yeah with fleshing out
more of lex luthor's plans and such
and the ultimate edition does make for a
much better movie watching
your video i gotta say completely
expanded my mind on so many things like
tiny details throughout that's what you
did with the man of steel video as well
i was like i never picked up on this i
never saw this of the tiniest bit of
details especially everything about
why lex is the way he is and his
philosophies and how much that
factors in to his motivations the
purpose for
everything that he's orchestrating and
he kind of expressed the
ideologies but i guess the trauma of his
dad was something that i didn't really
latch on to but the way you lay it out
here i'm like oh damn it is in the movie
yeah yeah and i mean that's something
worth at least giving credit for because
while i don't necessarily think that
everything is illuminated by
this video necessarily plays well in the
movie this did give me a
greater appreciation for a lot of the
ideas at the very ideas and intent
exactly yeah yeah and what they were
going for in meanings and themes
liked some more tiny details of
witnessing more of the character arc of
batman in here when he has lex and he's
threatening him at the very end and he
doesn't
hit him and he doesn't even brand him
going away from the harsher violence
yeah and even with the flash dream
sequence of noticing
the papers in the background because i
always thought that was kind of goofy i
like the nightmare sequence i thought
was cool
but my mind thought it was goofy of like
so he has this premonition
dream and then he wakes up in another
dream where the flashes
is getting all this information but
showcasing that it's not really a dream
with the papers flying in the background
and that maybe it was flashy was taking
him through all this stuff
i thought was a nice nugget to pick up
on and even from the opening sequence of
the nightmare scene how you said there
was the world engine
sound from man of steel i never picked
up on that like that oh that's the world
engine from man of steel
you know yeah and it seemed like that uh
was used a couple times to trigger
things in this movie and
yeah that gave me again a greater
appreciation too for the connective
tissue
that these movies have and that you know
must have come with some foresight from
zack snyder and crew the whole thing
with batman's theme like i i actually
as much as a big batman fan i am we had
the dark knight trilogy
right before this which made it
crystal clear batman does not kill like
that's
such a big part of bruce wayne in those
three movies it's such a thing
you know yeah the batman movies before
people weren't really complaining about
like when michael keaton killed
no one was really furious about that and
then to do
this right afterwards weirdly enough i
actually didn't really have a problem
with him killing
the gun thing actually distracted me
more than anything else
but the way he points out and
illustrates through here like no it's in
the script
it is and i feel like maybe my mind just
subconsciously picked up on it without
really realizing why i don't have an
issue with what batman's doing here in
terms of the violent ways he goes about
it and just straight up killing they do
lay it out that
he's kind of got this like uh just war
mentality about it
you know yeah and you know going up
against hardened career henchmen or
something
i have softened to that perspective and
i remember when zack snyder
first came out and he made that
statement about these aren't your naive
superheroes of the past these are more
gritty more realistic and at first i
kind of scoffed at that but i do
think that there is validity to that
because it is just another take among
many takes and given what batman's
career choice is
it stands to reason some people might
die and so
especially seeing then this video here
illustrating the fact that there is some
growth at least implied in terms of the
use of guns the use of murder yeah
and dealing with these crimes and stuff
in gotham cities
it makes it more interesting than i
initially set out for and i do think
that there is some credence there for
what zack snyder's point was too that
these are not your
you know granddads superman and batman
the thing with superman though here
that i can't fully meet you on board
with
is this is what i mean you do such a
great job at illustrating the intent
that you almost completely win me over
on some things
and there are some things you totally
have swayed to me more on like the
superman saving people montage
i agree with everything you're saying in
terms of yeah look he's doing the right
thing he's doing the good thing he's
trying to be a good hero
i think the reason why people got so mad
about it was because he looked like
[ __ ] miserable the entire time he was
doing it
yeah and he's got the suit on and he's
looking miserable but it seems like he's
fully fledged superman i almost wonder
if those moments might have played
better if he was just in plain clothes
he just seemed so stoic and serious
about any time he's around people
i'm not talking about like if he's
saving that rocket launch from going off
badly and
like okay yeah if you look like [ __ ]
this is a hard thing i get it and some
stuff i think was going for more visual
imagery
and try to thematically communicate
certain things like that moment
there's a flood and there's people on
the roof and they're looking up at
superman who's just hovering above them
in a slow motion sequence and you're
just looking at superman
a part of my brain at least and i know
other people did but my brain
was like why are you just hovering yeah
like do you not want to do this do you
not want to help them out and maybe the
whole purpose of that was to show
this is exhausting on him this is
emotionally tiresome for the guy
he's going to do it he's going to save
people but
he is at odds with is there truly a
purpose
so maybe the whole point of it is to
raise those questions and can i do this
without causing other damage in doing so
yeah and i i guess we never really got
anything from man of steel or bvs
where it looked like the joy of being a
hero
yeah that compassion and empathy that
would drive that theoretically and if
there was something
in be and maybe this superman is not
meant to have that at this point
like he just kind of i don't know why
i'm doing this yeah i feel like it's
a very valid thing coming out of man of
steel because so much of that movie
revels in his place in the world or lack
thereof and i think that the debate
about his role in the world in bvs is
also again the intent i think is
admirable but i do think
that the movie didn't articulate it well
because it doesn't show any dimension
yeah there's no
like positive anything tacked on to what
he's doing other than the logic of going
yeah he's completing these acts but he
does look so somber and i wish we could
have at least explored that
well because you have the moment with
the courthouse explosion
and that the face is the same face he
has
when people are around him being like oh
superman yeah
it's this weird singular note and again
i
i can understand what he must be feeling
but i do think it's a flaw of the movie
to put that in there so heavily and not
explain it if it's intentional or not
explore it or show you some dimensions
dynamics to clark
because those are two people too clark
and superman and there is an interplay
and
to really dumb it down into the overly
simplest terms it would just be nice to
see him crack a smile once in a while
or show some other emotions once in a
while like even his one-liners
aren't that he doesn't seem like he's
enjoying the one-liners at all
you'll learn i don't remember what we
said in our non-spoiler review when we
first reviewed this movie but
good thing i've always been i feel like
i've always
been okay with lex and this actually
just further went to go like yeah now i
really have no problem with lex
other than the fact of like yeah this
plan is like really convoluted
at the same time i've liked jesse
eisenberg's weird accenture take and
we've said it multiple times that we do
enjoy it it's not my preferred lex
luthor but for what it is in this movie
i think his lex actually works for this
film yeah and i think that that's
something that you can let go of if you
know you're not necessarily holding
everything to the classic depictions of
the comics or something like that and
it's true
i think it's a good point that he
brought up about how any time recycling
a character it's a risk you know you're
running a risk
i think that this did a nice job of just
at least touching in on what his
motivations are for the people who
it wasn't as clear for and yeah i liked
especially the little details he brought
up about like his
one-on-one conversation with holly
hunter and the way you can see like that
anger and that rage boiling up so
as much as you know his quirky tickish
demeanor i understand why that upsets
people i think the
truly maniacal angry lex is in there you
know and it's apparent in the movie
i feel like it's all there and then it's
the part of the movie that i never
really
to gripe with yeah i think batman
working out is still very unnecessary to
fight superman
i think let's just make it harder for
him when he has this fight
he's gonna make you sore no amount of
human physical strength you build up is
really gonna do it if anything should be
working on your speed
you're relying on hydraulics my man you
got a mech suit
for this purpose maybe stretch he's just
for his mental game
yeah he just wants to feel them i'm just
so angry i need to fight right now
the emails and those scenes i i i've
never really latched on to
i didn't really feel much of an argument
to be made here but i'll admit
i think the scene's kind of goofy but
whenever i've like googled the scene on
youtube i always watch the whole thing
being like hey look at them it's cool
commercial it's a good it's cool i
actually like it when it's not in
context
yeah and i will again give you the
credit that yes it would make total
sense for batman to be compiling a list
of super folks in case
superman becomes a threat i just yeah i
don't think the movie itself articulated
it very gracefully
yeah the ultimate edition really is a
lot better though you should check it
out i i would like to
this actually you your recommendation
and this video have clinched it
and now the martha scene there's a
couple of times at least where you said
that it had nothing to do with the fact
that they both
share the same name the moms it has
something to do with that yeah
i wouldn't i'm not even going to really
use that against you i'm just saying
that i
i think everything you said actually is
a part of it
and the fact that they share the names
is included in that as well i i wouldn't
say that
it has nothing to do with it because
it's supposed to trigger that it's
supposed to
direct root memory you do say it's a
spark i think it's more than just a
spark i think it it
all factors in i wouldn't try to
discount it i i think the problem is
people
only thought it was that yeah i do agree
in
in his assessment that yeah once people
had that knee jerk
they commit to it yeah you really opened
my eyes on the
power of that scene that's what i got to
give you a lot of credit for
the intent there's a lot of themes and
character moments in within that that i
was like oh you know i never read into
any of that i'll say that you
persuaded me on a lot there the thing i
can't agree on though
not really the save martha line it's
more of
yeah i get if superman's [ __ ] annoyed
with batman leading into the fight i i
would get that but i'm like
you still had plenty of like i did a
video
when this movie came out on like dvd or
something of like the amount of times he
could have said
save martha or like explain the
situation there's so many breaths in
between
you can just like say say just a couple
of sentences
my mom is kidnapped we need to go save
relax like you're two sentences away at
any moment and you just he just spends
so much time going
you need to listen to me listen to me
you need to listen
no just say something you insisting on
listening isn't working so just get to
the point
yeah there's so many times you could
have just gotten straight forward with
it yeah
while i feel like i actually oh and the
whole thing with the same martha line i
i i like a lot more with the context you
provided and perhaps revisiting it
i will be like oh yeah man freaking
cinnamon once is right it's right there
it's all there yeah but i don't think i
can ever agree with
no he he had plenty of time to
especially like or he could have done
something else like he could have
lasered all those games or something i
don't care if you're annoyed
by batman i feel like that should be
more of a reason for him to
be more urgent with getting to the point
yeah exactly so that this doesn't end up
with us creating more damage for
ourselves
and not saving yeah like your annoyance
towards batman shouldn't out
i don't care what stage of superman
you're at your annoyance for batman
shouldn't outweigh the urgency to save
your mom's life yeah exactly
especially if the same martha lions has
to be like the biggest [ __ ] thing in
the world
you know yeah i think that could have
just
straight up could have been changed i
liked your reasoning a lot for the
martha
scene it's another one of those examples
from this video where i think you've
helped me kind of realize
the richness of the intent and what is
there subtextually
true i still don't think it's a really
well articulated scene
well it might be up i mean how many
times have you seen this movie
a couple because it's it's easier for me
to get on board with everything he's
saying
i've seen the theatrical twice and i've
seen the ultimate edition once
okay and then with all that and being
like oh yeah it is there
you do have to kind of pick up on a lot
of these details
for the richness of it to really hit
sometimes that's the kind of filmmaker
zack center is and i feel like cinema
wins does a great job of pointing out
those additional visual nuances that i
just
that kind of fly over my head sometimes
yeah that's fair i mean he is a very
he doesn't make picturesque lot of use
of that deepest bro in the world
yeah it kind of feels like sometimes
you know your your bro dude who read ein
rand
you know but yeah man i think you did a
great job with this video you swayed me
on a lot more things
i respect your positivity and love for
even the moments i disagree with you on
likewise because yeah i like the movie
uh i i do i especially like the ultimate
edition
i'm excited to see that because i i
really didn't like the theatrical
i know like it really brought my day
down yeah i know it did i remember
driving with you you were like wow
you're usually really bummed i was
yeah really you felt insulted by
hollywood you seemed like you just
watched zero dark thirty again it's like
i spent this money on this yeah watch
the ultimate edition because
it definitely makes a difference we'll
do but yeah guys subscribe to cinema
wins
makes great videos i've watched like all
the harry potter ones on my own and
fantastic beasts like i love
everything this guy has to say i'm
watching the grindelwald video i don't
know if you made a grindelwald one i
haven't seen the grindelwald one yet
that's the next challenge
thank you so much if you like cinema
wins hit the like button for this video
subscribe click that bell last but not
least
bradley bledsoe joker homeboy yeah i'm
gonna
get get there homeboy this homeboy let
me lead
bradley shout out bradley he's got a
cool channel
he does music talks about movies has his
wonderful joker video essay
and when we talked to him on discord a
little plug there
he talked to him on discord we see his
office and it's nothing but joker
posters
uh memorabilia wow you know a lot of
times you go to youtubers movie channels
and it's all that's crap funko pops and
other
movie images get as wide of a net of ips
as possible
not this guy you see all corners of the
room and unification
the walls are that maroon color of his
suit
and the posters on the walls snatch the
walls this guy likes one movie
and he's gonna die on that hill but you
know what i admire the passion
my friend he brought a big smile to our
face he's a lovely guy to talk to
very insightful very friendly he's one
of the people who really helps build the
community on our discord as well
it's nice getting to know you bradley
pleasure to have you on our patreon page
hope you stick around for as long as you
possibly can
and keep kicking ass in the youtube
sphere as well dude